- Madison's your ex?
Oh fuck.
(upbeat music)
My roommate's away.
- That's awesome, really good news.
- Mmm-hmm.
(chuckling)
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Okay, and we're done.
- Okay.
- Well...
- Oh.
(chuckling)
(gentle music)
- Well, last year, we did
a study abroad to Italy.
- Oh, nice!
- It was so cool.
Actually, I have some pictures.
- Oh, let's see.
Oh!
Oh my God, I've been there.
Yeah, it has like the best ice cream.
- It does, yeah!
That's real.
- Oh my God, how do you know Madison?
- She's my ex-girlfriend.
- Madison's your ex?
Oh fuck.
- What?
How well do you know her?
- She's my roommate.
- Oh.
- Ugh.
Fuck, I am the worst
person in the entire world.
- Shh, we broke up a few months ago.
We're definitely over each other.
It's fine.
- I don't know, oh my God,
this is not a good idea.
I should not be in bed with you.
- Okay, if that's what
you want, then it's fine,
but I really like you, Bridget.
I'm having a good time.
(chuckling)
- Yeah, me too.
Ugh, this is so bad!
I mean, she's a really cool girl.
She'll be cool; she'll be fine, right?
- Yeah, I don't know, yes, yeah.
Okay.
- Okay.
(toilet flushing)
Shit, you fucking idiot, Bridget.
I've got to tell her.
- Oh, nuts, I got work today?
Jesus!
(upbeat music)
- Jack!
- Hey, Maddy.
- Hi.
What are you doing here?
- Uh...
- I didn't tell you where I lived.
- No, I know.
(nervous mumbling)
- Did you ask somebody where I lived?
'Cause, Jack, that's crazy, okay?
Like this is over; I don't
wanna get back together
and I think the longer we do this the...
(suspenseful music)
Did you sleep with my roommate?
(upbeat music)
- You can do this.
Okay...
Fuck.
- Oh my God.
Bridget, hey.
- Hey.
- So, you hooked up with Jack then?
- Shit.
I was gonna tell you; I was
literally about to tell you.
I'm so sorry; I didn't
even realize it was him.
- I mean, I talk about him so much.
- I know, but I've never
seen a picture of him.
- I mean, I believe you.
I don't think you were trying to hurt me.
I don't wanna be with him.
He's way too immature for me.
So, sorry, but it's true.
(chuckling)
It's fine that you guys hooked up, okay?
You have my blessing or whatever.
He's not my property.
- Thank you so much.
I'm so sorry.
I had a really good time
with him, it's just...
You know, next time he comes over,
I'll let you know beforehand, okay?
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
- Okay, yeah, of course.
Next time he comes over.
(upbeat music)